Joyeux anniversaire Nicolas !
Joyeux anniversaire
- Souffle !
- Souffle, fait un vœu !
- Je souhaite...
Devenir astronaute !
Oui ! Astronaute !
- Ou alors pompier !
- Oui pompier !
- C'est bien pompier ?
- Le camion !
Oui le camion !
Avoir des super pouvoirs et le camion, c'est super ça !
Dinosaure.
- Comment ça dinosaure ?
- Trop cool !
C'est pour être un dinosaure ? Je comprends pas.
Ou avoir un dinosaure ?
Je sais pas, on aime les dinosaures c'est tout.
Oui c'est trop cool les dinosaures !
Et puis peut être que je pourrai me marier avec Léa plus tard ?
- Ah oui !
- Oh oui !
- On pourra lui faire un bisou la tête a l'envers.
- Dans notre camion !
- Qui sera dans l'espace. Allez souffle Nicolas, vas-y !
- Souffle ! Allez !
- Souffle !
Vas-y souffle !
Les cadeaux ! Les cadeaux !
Joyeux anniversaire Nico !
Joyeux anniversaire !
- Vas-y souffle !
- Fais un voeu !
Je souhaite...
Faire du bon gros rock !
Ouais grave.
Sans oublier de sauver des gens d'un incendie en parallèle, c'est pas mal...
Non mais bien sûr ! Rockstar et on sauve des gens en péril, les deux combinés, c'est stylé.
Avec ça Chloé elle va trop vouloir sortir avec moi c'est sûr.
Chloé ? Comment ça Chloé ?
C'est avec Léa qu'on voulait se marier nous !
Écoute, Léa elle a déménagé à la fin du CM1 à Valenciennes, donc qu'est ce qu'on fait  ?
On prend un billet de train, on va dans une ville qu'on connait pas, on sait pas où elle habite
on lui a parlé cinq fois dans notre vie ou alors...
On sort avec Chloé ?
Ah on sort avec Chloé !
Quoi ?
Non mais... On t'a pas dit ?
De quoi ? Qu'est-ce qu'on m'a pas dit ?
Tu sais très bien, on va pas devenir astronaute !
Mais pourquoi ?
- Qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour être astronaute ?
-  On fait des tests !
Mais avant ça ?
Oui ok... On fait des études supérieures.
- Pfff
- C'est pas longtemps ! Sept ou huit ans c'est pas non plus...
Les études c'est mort de chez mort !
Alors que pour être rockstar, il suffit de faire de la guitare.
Adieu astronaute.
Quoi ? C'est n'importe quoi ! Pourquoi pompier il reste ?
Parce que tout le monde sait que c'est populaire auprès des filles. Et nous on va...
Ouais, surtout Chloé !
Surtout Chloé on va bien la...
- Ouais bien sûr Chloé.
- Super sympa les gars.
Et dinosaure qui reste, ça on m'explique ?
Non mais moi je suis là que quand Nico il est défoncé.
Tu peux partir astronaute.
Nicolas enfin c'est...
On y croyait, c'était notre rêve.
Alors je me permet d'insister mais super-héros c'est pas mal !
Non mais toi Spider-man tu dégages en faite.
Ah j'en été sûr mais bon j'ai tenté !
Salut, moi c'est testeur de jeux vidéo.
- Ah ouais !
- Génial !
Trop bien ! Beaucoup mieux que Spider-man !
Grave !
Allez Nico, souffle.
Allez Souffle Nico !
Vas-y souffle !
Ouais Nicolas !
Merci les gars !
Je suis trop fier de toi.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Mange-le ce quatre-quart !
Joyeux anniversaire Nico !
Joyeux anniversaire !
Allez souffle, souffle !
Le vœu ! Le vœu ! Le vœu !
Je souhaite...
Faire le tour du monde.
Rencontrer des cultures, s'enrichir des expériences humaines
Mieux comprendre le monde qui nous entoure pour mieux se comprendre soi-même.
Avoir notre diplôme de comptabilité.
Mais ce n'est pas un rêve ça, man.
Ah bon ? Parce que vu nos résultats au dernier semestre
si on arrive à valider notre année c'est un miracle.
Mais man, c'est pas un diplôme qui va nous ouvrir sur le monde qui nous entoure.
Et avec quel argent on va partir ?
En travaillant l'été, les vendanges...
On a un plan à la mairie...
Oui, super la vie, faire des petits boulots  tout claquer le lendemain.
Bien, bonne idée.
Attends parce que moi j'ai parlé avec Morgane, elle adore les voyages
Si je lui dis que j'ai fait un tour du monde, je vais la pécho !
Ah ouais ? C'est en partant un an qu'on va réussir à sortir avec ?
On va revenir, elle sera fiancée avec quelqu'un on aura l'air con !
À un moment faut être réaliste les gars, faut se réveiller un petit peu
Faut avoir un plan de carrière c'est important.
Tu cherches quoi ?
Les autres.
Y'a des autres ?
- Qui ça ?
- Pompier, rockstar...
- Pompier ? Faut être réaliste, tu sais faire combien de pompes?
Une ?
- Un peu moins...
- Voilà !
Et rockstar ! La guitare qu'on t'a offerte à Noël, t'en as joué combien de fois ?
Non mais ça fait hyper mal aux doigts, là, les cordes...
Après sur Guitar Hero on a fait Free Bird en difficile, ce qui n'est pas dégueu.
J'ai mon petit niveau.
Ah ouais d'accord, tu veux parler toi ?
Testeur de jeux vidéos ça n'existe pas c'est pas un métier, c'est un loisir.
Il te faut un diplôme pour avoir un métier, comme être comptable par exemple.
Tu n'existes pas.
Après si on boit trois-quatre bières, moi je peux revenir.
Super responsable, bien joué les gars.
Putain mais arrête de nous faire chier man, c'est notre anniversaire on a le droit de rêver.
Vas-y souffle Nicolas, et je te jure un jours on va le faire ce tour du monde.
Vas-y souffle...
Le vœu, le vœu !
Cul sec ! Cul sec !
- J'adore l'endroit !
- C'est vrai ?
C'est trop une bonne idée!
Joyeux anniversaire chéri.
Tu es adorable.
Allez souffle !
Ok...
Je souhaite...
Une augmentation.
Non, moi je n'étais pas parti là dessus à la base.
Ca fait quand même quatre ans qu'on est dans la boîte, pardon mais une petite prime ne serait pas de refus.
Exactement et ça pourrait nous aider à monter un dossier d'emprunt.
Morgane nous dit souvent qu'elle aimerait partir en vacance, il nous faut de l'argent.
Sinon ça sent pas bon pour le couple.
Excusez moi mais, vous êtes qui ?
- Moi c'est Augmentation.
- Propriétaire.
OK... Où est globe-trotteur ?
Jamais entendu parlé.
Une prime ce serait bien. J'ai vu un petit peu les prix des appartements en banlieue
ça grimpe pas mal en ce moment.
Oui peut être que la banque peut nous faire un prêt a un taux pas trop dégueu.
Franchement j'y crois pas vu les marchés actuels. Il faudrait peut être passer par un courtier....
Pardon je t'ai pris ton voeu !
Oui, sympa !
T'inquiètes pas tu es dedans.
C'est gentil.
Tu exagères. Qu'est ce que c'est ?
Une fiat multipla ? Les codes nucléaires ?
- À ton avis ?
- Un tank ?
Un paquebot !
**Musique**
Elle est trop belle.
Je souhaite...
- Qu'elle devienne proprié-
- Qu'elle fasse le tour du monde !
Et le monde elle va le voir tourner depuis son hublot.
Et elle va enregistrer des albums dans l'espace ! Dans l'espace mon pote !
Mais trop man !
Et si elle se faisait mordre par une araignée radioactive ?
- Ouais.
- Ouais ?
Et elle aura un camion !
- Qu'est ce que tu fais là toi ?
- Alors je me permets d'insister
parce qu'investir dans la pierre c'est quand même un bon moyen-
Mais ferme-la !
- Ta gueule !
Elle va faire des trucs incroyables !
Elle pourra être avocate ?
- Elle sera la première à marcher sur Mars.
- Elle pourra écrire des livres
- Elle va construire des ponts !
- Elle va nous faire rêver !
- Ou faire de l'électricité !
- Présidente des États Unis.
Elle va avoir un prix Nobel.
Ou alors elle sera au chômage, comme papa.
Elle fera SON choix et ce sera le bon.